[Music]
hi my name is Daniel Shan ski and today
I'll be showing you how to do an
animation to expend cells in a ListView
so if you have a list you with certain
data and you want to show extra content
associated with every single cell
instead of taking the user to a new page
you can simply click on the cell expand
it show the extra content collapse it a
few of the things about animation is
that as the cell expands it moves around
all the atoms around it to make room for
the new extra content and furthermore
this new size persists so if you were to
expand a cell then scroll away from and
then come back to it the new size will
persist of the expanded cell until it is
collapsed manual by the user by clicking
on the cell again a couple of the tricks
and the problems that they came across
while implementing this animation is the
fact that when you animate a cell when
you change the layout of a cell what's
going to happen is that some of the some
of the other cells around it are going
to disappear they're going to be moved
outside the bit let the balance of the
ListView
and when this happens you no longer have
a reference to those views so even
though you still need to animate them to
achieve that animation effect that's
problem number one the second problem
when when working with this is that when
you change the layout of a certain view
in the ListView the container what's
going to happen is that the ListView
will try to rearrange the cells as it
wants to make room for it but if you
want to achieve some sort of custom
expansion such that when you expand the
cell all the content should be visible
or as much of it as can be visible to
the user should be visible once you're
going to want to rearrange the cells in
a way that's most optimal for for your
application and in this case you need to
tell the ListView exactly how to how to
place them on the screen so going
straight into the demo here we have a
list view of chameleons rocks and
flowers and say click on a cell see how
it expands displacing you text and then
you can click again to close it this
works for every single cell it is it
works for extra content of different
sizes and you can also see that see that
as a cell
expands and collapses the content the
extra content the text actually fades in
and fades out and this is not only
restricted to text this will also work
with other types of layouts another
interesting thing about this is that say
this cell is at the edge and you want to
expand it you can see that it'll animate
in to make room for it so if you're
weird to animate to bring this flower
down and we click here it'll actually
animate upwards instead of animating
downwards and then when I click on it it
makes room for all the other cells in
them enemies then back in so dropping
jumping straight to the code here in
custom ListView which extends the
ListView which can expand and collapse
cells we are first we initiate an item
let click listener such that when you
click click and click again you can
expand or collapse it respectively and
then scrolling down furthermore this is
the get top and bottom translations
method so what this does this can be
customized by you depending kind of user
experience you'd like but what in this
specific case what I did is always try
to maximize the amount of content that's
this paid to the user and all it is is
really just a little bit of math a
little bit of arithmetic using the
bounds of the ListView using how much
what the current offset is and using
what the size of the list view of the
current visible part of the ListView is
as well so this will return a bottom on
the top and all this will say is how
much the bottom and the top bounds of
the expanding or the collapsing cell
should be modified by and use you can
use these as a reference to animate all
the cells around the cells being
expanded or collapsed scrolling down
furthermore we really expand the you
method which takes in the view that's
being expanded and before we actually
expand anything there's a few things we
need to do we need to store what the old
bounds of the cell it's about to be
expanded is and we also need to store
the top and bottom bounds of all the
cells that are around that expand the
cell that's going to be expanded after
that we get a reference to the expanding
layout so even though it's not visible
at first the expanding layout is present
in every single cell except its
visibility is set to gone so it's not
effect its not being rendered it's not
affecting the layout at all but by
sending it to visible
now tell her that we wanna and by
setting it to visible and having the
cell have its layout set to wrap content
were rushing to be doing is invoking a
request layout call without without
having that be here explicitly because
we know that now something that was gone
has been convinced about and we need to
render it and like I like I've mentioned
if you have my other animations we what
we're going to want to do is add an on
pre-drill listener
so by invoking said visible we're going
to change the layout of this cell along
with the with the balance and the
layouts of the cells around it and on
layout and on measure will get called
the final values for all the cells will
be will be computed but they will not
yet be drawn on the screen so this is
the best place to run an animation
except the thing about this animation
right here that's going to be a little
different is that we're going to have
two passes in on preacher instead of
just one
during the first free draw pass what we
want to do is we want to offset the
content in the ListView in such a way
such that after we invoke a layout once
again all the cells that we want
rendered on the screen will be visible
and will be accessible to the user so if
we want if we were not to have this
first pass the list you would arrange
all the cells in a way most convenient
for the solicitor to display the content
but if this is not but seeing how we're
animating the top and bottom balance in
a very custom manner what we need to do
is specify exactly where we which cells
we want to we want to have visible the
way this is done is through a little bit
of math determining how much we need to
offset it by but the key method that I'm
using here is set selection from top so
after determining which cell is going to
be at the very top after my custom
animations my custom changes for the top
and bottom bounds are run I know what
the first visible position is going to
be afterwards and I also know what it's
offset is going to be from the top so
doing doing some math then calling set
selection on top from top I said I said
the offset that I want for the ListView
and then I call request layout so what
this is going to do is render all the
cells that I need to be rendered on the
screen after having the list should be
offset by how much I need I'm also going
to be returning full
from entrepreneur because all I'm doing
here is offsetting the content but I
don't want I don't want it to be I don't
want the current state of the ListView
to be redrawn so because if I were to
redraw it in two different states it
would be a very janky and not a very
pleasant animation for the user so
returning false but still not having
removed the pre-drill listener what's
going to happen is it's going to come
back to on preacher after the new values
have been recomputed at which point we
will no longer need the pre-draw
listener so then we then we go down we
can retrieve the values from before for
the top and bottom bound changes and
then we can get straight into calculate
on the animations that we need so before
the animation took place we store the
top and bottom bounds for all the cells
that were previously visible and so if
it was visible before it before the
animation and the cell is still visible
after animation we're going to go into
this else case and all we need to do is
animate the bounds from the before state
to the after state which is very
straightforward
this this is what happens when the
parent what I'm going to is this what
happens when the parent of the view is
not not so this means it was visible
before the before the let the layout
change and it's also present after the
layout change but say the cell expanded
so much that the cell will no longer be
visible after the layer change we're
going to see that our that our views of
parent is null so it's no long no longer
contained in the ListView but up here
when when I created in my hash map I
said set has transient to true so what
that did is even though it's no longer
part of the ListView
this view is not going to be recycled
and as long as I store a reference to
the solicit myself I can still make use
of it after after the layout has taken
place as long as I long as I have a
reference to it so go throwing down here
all I'm going to do is add the exact
same animation as I do for cells that
are still visible after the layout
except I'm also going to add it to this
array of mine called M use to draw which
is going to tell me that this is a view
that needs to be animated of the screen
just for animation purposes but it isn't
that
doesn't actually need to be rendered for
the purposes of ListView now for the
purses of the ListView use so scrolling
down furthermore I add an animation to
actually expand the balance of the cell
being expanded and then I also fade in
the expanding layout text so this does
not necessarily have to be text but the
layout itself is faded in by animating
its alpha value from 0 to 1 then during
the animation itself I wanted to seal my
ListView to prevent some weird behavior
that the you if the user were to scroll
during that time and once my animation
completes one thing that I really have
to do is make sure to set the transient
say to false for any views that
previously had it to true so that these
views don't get stored but can actually
be recycled and make less you scrolling
more efficient afterwards so that that
was expand view now in this patch draw
what's going to happen is the only
things that I would want to draw on to
the screen that are not on the screen
right now are views that were were in
the ListView but are no longer the list
you afterwards I only need a reference
to these during the animation because
once the animation completes the user
should not be able to track with them
anymore and so since I have a reference
to the view itself all I need to do is a
chat is translate the canvas
appropriately just its top value because
the cell takes up the whole width I just
need to modify where it's located
vertically on the screen I draw the view
onto the canvas and then I translate it
back so that the next cell to be drawn
will be drawn in the correct location as
well scrolling down furthermore into
collapse you it's going to be very
similar in most ways so before the code
before the cell is collapsed I want to
store the top and bottom bounds of all
the cells prior to the collapse I want
to set transition to true so nothing
gets recycled during the collapse of
collapsing animation and then the only
important thing really important thing
to note here is that I know I'm not
changing the expanding layout visibility
from visible to gone what I'm actually
doing is setting the height of the
layout to Avira to a custom height
I calculated that I pre-computer before
which is what its default height is when
it's in a collapsed state and the reason
I can't set the visibility to go on and
just work with the layer change from
there is because I want to get that
fading effect as the cell is collapsing
on the expanding layout and that fading
effect cannot be achieved if my if the
expanding layered visibility is gone or
invisible so by setting the height to a
constant value I can then invoke a
layout and add an on pre-draw listener
like before very similar to the expand
view method I'm going to have two passes
the first pass is going to offset the
ListView in such a ways to account for
the custom collapse that I'm going to
achieve and once again I'm going to call
set selection from top request a layout
and make sure to return false so the
transient state of the ListView does not
get drawn onto the screen and then since
the pre-draw listener is now you have
been removed when a request has been
called again it'll come back here for
its second pass where I will firstly
loop through all the visible children in
the ListView if I find that I do have
access to the old bounds of that view in
the ListView that means that this view
was present in listing before and after
the collapse which at which point all I
need to do is is update its bounds and
then later animate them but if I find
that the I don't have access to the old
bounds of this cell that means that this
cell became visible only after the
collapse of the view so the collapse of
the view actually made room for new
cells to appear but since I don't know
what their old bounds was what their old
bounds were I don't have a reference
point from where I want to animate them
so I just I use the top and bottom
translation values to account for that
scrolling down here I loop through I
loop through all these same views and
add the animations to actually animate
them from these old bounds to their new
bounds I also want to animate the
collapse of the collapsing cell and I
want to animate the expanding layout
from a value of one to values here so it
disappears then I play all of these
together in an animator set and then
once it's actually done what I do is set
the expanding layered visibility to gone
so it doesn't get rendered on the screen
at all anymore and nor is it visible and
I also update my layer parameters to a
rep content because when it's gone I
want to just wrap the content which
means that none of the expanding layout
should be wrapped and then here get
animation this is actually how I animate
the top and bottom bounds in use since
top and bottom have associated setters
in views called set top and set bottom
these values can be animated as I would
like them to be and then I just return
an object animator that does what I need
the one other thing that I wanted to
mention in this animation is how I
actually managed to achieve the collapse
of the expanding layout as while fading
it out so what's what's going to happen
is when I set the height of the layout
to be collapsed 8 the list you will not
want to render the expanding layer
because it's not visible on the screen
so what I do here is override on measure
on size and on size change and what I'm
telling you to do is that when it
doesn't want to display the expanding
the expanding layout content but if it
previously was in expanding layout state
by overriding on measure and returning
the bigger height as opposed to a
smaller height will will keep it visible
and that's that lets me animate its
alpha value and once it's complete
completely collapsed that's when I set
it to gone because I don't have anything
else to do with it so that's how you can
expand expand eclipse cells and ListView
thanks for watching